[Música]
hola profesores de latinoamérica soy con
ellos e iliana bienvenidos a la
formación inicial de khan academy
estamos a punto de iniciar un fascinante
viaje de aprendizaje pero primero veamos
juntos el camino que tenemos por delante
para comenzar desde el panel de profesor
/ la pestaña de recursos allí
encontrarás la descripción del camp para
maestros
[Música]
haz clic en regístrate y te llevará a
una página para que completes un
formulario sigue las instrucciones para
inscribirte debes hacer clic en
confirmar inscripción y ver esta página
para completar el proceso
después de eso estarás listo para
comenzar el curso
la formación inicial tiene una unidad y
cinco lecciones comenzaremos con
conociendo a la misión de khan academy
que habla sobre nuestro compromiso con
la educación de alta calidad y la
experiencia de aprendizaje que deseamos
brindar a continuación tenemos la
lección recorrida de la plataforma que
muestra las principales funciones de
navegación y cómo configurar una cuenta
la tercera lección herramientas para
maestros muestra todos nuestros recursos
desde la construcción de clases hasta el
acceso a los informes de desempeño de
los alumnos en implementación aprenderás
a hacer uso de los recursos de khan
academy con tus estudiantes y también
muestra las estrategias pedagógicas
testimonios y sugerencias de profesores
de escuelas públicas y privadas de
méxico y perú por último tenemos la
lección próximos pasos que explora las
diferentes oportunidades de educación
continua para seguir aprendiendo y no
cuando ven clases la formación inicial
fue diseñada para que los profesores los
coordinadores pedagógicos y los
directores de escuela puedan
experimentar carne
como lo hacen los estudiantes por lo
tanto para completar el curso deben
dominar las habilidades realizar los
ejercicios y seguir haciéndolo bien en
la prueba final esto les ayudará a
dominar el uso de herramientas para
sacarle el mayor provecho a nuestra
plataforma
el futuro de tu desarrollo profesional
está en tus manos
comienza la formación inicial ahora
mismo y descubre cómo khan academy puede
ampliar las posibilidades en tu salón de
clases
tienes alguna pregunta sobre nuestro
curso visita nuestro centro de ayuda y
revisa la sección de preguntas
frecuentes hasta pronto